ROMAIN GUY: Good afternoon,
everyone.
And welcome to the session
on writing
custom views for Android.
And the title is a bit
misleading, because we won't
be showing code, or we won't
be writing code.
My name is Romain Guy.
And this is Adam Powell.
And we both work on the Android
Framework Team at Google.
Adam works a lot on
the UI Toolkit.
And you have seen his work in
the action bar, the view
pager, the support library.
He's the mind behind
all of that.
I focus mostly on graphics,
performance, and animations.
But I've done a little bit of
UI Toolkit in the past.
So I think I know what
I'm talking about.
ADAM POWELL: So why would you
actually want to write your
own custom views?
Isn't the framework good
enough for that?
Are we missing something?
Well, usually the framework
has what you need.
But between the framework and
the support library, you kind
of have what you need
to get everything
in the design guide.
And reusing those framework
components ensures the user is
familiar with the
patterns there.
And hopefully the components
are stable.
But sometimes you just really
need to stand out.
So just like Larry was saying
this morning, your app is
doing something unique.
Otherwise why are
you writing it?
You might need graphs, other
data visualizations, other
things that just are
really unique to
what your app is doing.
Maybe you need some
sort of custom
interaction with your content.
I mean, not everything
fits within a list
view or a scroll view.
And touch is a great
way to feel
connected to your content.
And writing a view gives you
full control over that.
So who here uses
RelativeLayout, for an example?
A lot of hands.
That's great.
Probably because this
guy told you to.
ROMAIN GUY: Now a while ago,
I wrote a blog that was
misinterpreted.
And now everybody thinks they
should be using RelativeLayout
all the time.
Please don't.
ADAM POWELL: It's a
great view, right?
ROMAIN GUY: It works.
We can get to that later,
if we have time.
ADAM POWELL: Sure.
So RelativeLayout will measure
child views more than once in
order to solve some of the
constraints that you give it.
So being generic has a cost.
A little domain knowledge
can go a long way for
optimization.
Really, there should always be
one part of your app that can
catch someone's eye from across
a room, something
that's instantly identifiable.
If one of your users is using
your app in a coffee shop,
someone clear across the
room should be able to
tell what it is.
So you want to make your
app fun and satisfying.
And the design guidelines
are great.
But apps that do unique things
will always beg for some sort
of innovative ways to do them.
So members of the Android
community have already given
several talks lately that have
been really great, and given a
lot of information on writing
custom views.
And not only that, there
are a lot of great
code examples available.
And Android Open Source project
itself is a great
resource for you to look at.
But realistically, we want to
keep this talk a little bit
more abstract, as you
were saying earlier.
So in writing our own custom
views, and helping others
write them as well, we found
a lot of common patterns
emerged from this.
And we found ourselves
giving the same
recommendations over and over.
And we're going to spend most of
our time here today talking
about those experiences and what
worked well, what didn't,
and what can really help you
from getting caught in a
[? rapple ?]
of the internal design
of your components.
So to do that, we still need
some context about how the
system works.
So we'll go ahead
and start with--
ROMAIN GUY: But just before on
the previous slide, don't
believe the "Tips and
Trick" bullet.
We removed that section.
So there won't be tips
and there won't be
tricks for you today.
ADAM POWELL: Well, we might
have some tips and tricks
along the way.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah,
So we'll start with
Live of a View.
So how many of you have
ever seen the
Activity Lifecycle Diagram?
All right.
How many of you understand the
Activity Lifecycle Diagram?
You're a bunch of liars.
I've been on the team
for six years.
I still don't get it.
I exaggerate.
But it's complicated.
But the Lifecycle Diagram of
Activities makes guarantees
about the methods that will
be invoked on your
activities and when.
And we have similar
things for views.
It's a lot simpler,
as you will see.
But we have guarantees
that we can promise.
So the life of a view is
made of three things.
We have the attachment
and detachment.
And this is actually a very
important part of
the life of a view.
And I've never or rarely seen
articles online talk about it,
or examples focusing on that.
Then with traversals that you
may know as drawing and layout
and measurement.
And finally, we have the state
saving and restoring.
So let's get started with the
attachment and detachment.
Actually, another quick poll.
How many of you have used that
method onAttachedToWindow?
All right, that's pretty good.
So whenever you attach a view
to a parent-- so you call a
ViewGroup, that add view-- if
that parent already belongs to
window, in UI Toolkit
[? Balance ?] we said that the
view gets attached
to the window.
So you get this call back,
onAttachedToWindow.
And this is where the view
knows it can be active.
So this is where you should
start allocating any resources
you might need.
This is where you can register
listeners on other pieces of
the application on the system.
And for instance, in list view,
when you attach a list
view to a window, this is when
we attach a listener to your
adaptor after so that list
view knows when the data
changes in the adaptor.
And again, you should
take a look at the
source code of Android.
So if you look at the source
code of view.java, or
AbsListView.java, you will see
the kind of things that we do
in onAttachedToWindow.
But even more important is the
second callback called
onDetachedFromWindow.
So we call that callback
whenever a view is removed
from its parent and if that
parent is attached to window.
This can happen for a
number of reasons.
Maybe the view is getting
recycled in the list view when
you're scrolling.
Maybe you called remove view
on the parent of that view.
Or maybe we are tearing
down the activity.
When we tear down the activity
when there's a finished event
on the activity, we're going
to remove every view.
And we're going to detach
them from the window.
This callback is very important,
because this is
where you can stop doing
any kind of work
that was already scheduled.
So if you had scheduled an
animation, like a scroll or a
fling, if you had a background
thread running, you can stop
those things right here.
Also, if you had allocated
resources like a drawing cache
of some sort, or any other
resource that your custom view
might need, this is a
very good place to
clean up those resources.
A good example is for the
hardware renderer.
So in Android 3.0, we added
Hardware Acceleration.
And we created a lot of native
objects that attached views
during the lifecycle
of the view.
And when the view gets detached
from the window, this
is where we can destroy those
native objects, because we
know that the view will not be
shown on screen anymore.
So we make sure to promise
when you get
onDetachFromWindow, you can
destroy all these resources.
Of course, this is a promise
that we make.
But sometimes when you implement
your own custom
views, and you try to be, let's
say, smart about your
lifecycle of the view, you might
run into real issues
where the view will be detached
but it's not.
Or the view will think it
is attached, it is not
attached and it is.
We've run into a number of
bugs like that in our own
applications.
ADAM POWELL: A couple.
ROMAIN GUY: So be very careful
when you use AdView,
RemoveView.
And View Group has a number
of methods where you can
temporarily detach a view
from the window.
So if you're using those
methods, be very careful.
And that's about it for the
lifecycle of a view.
So what is missing?
What is missing is all the
events that you get on an
activity, so things like
onPause, onResume, onStop.
And we have a lot of requests
from people who are asking to
get those lifecycle events
on View itself.
The reason why we don't have
those lifecycle events on view
is about abstraction
and layering.
The way the Android framework is
built, we try to layer our
packages on top of each other.
So what you see on the side
right here is actually the
layering that we have
internally.
So the android.app package that
contains activity and
context sits on top of pretty
much everything else.
At the bottom, we have
android.widget, where you have
your text view, your list
view, your image
view, things like that.
And that sits on top
of android.view.
So you could actually build a
version, I would say the fork
of Android, where you get
rid of android.widget.
And you just keep
android.view.
And the system would
just work.
So instead of adding those
activity lifecycle events to
views, what you should do is
create your own sets of
listeners or callbacks
in your custom views.
So here, there's a very simple
example of custom listeners
that you could specify
on your view.
And it will be the
responsibility of the activity
to invoke those callbacks
on the view.
Another way of doing it is just
to add methods straight
to your class.
If you have used GL SurfaceView
that's used to do
OpenGL rendering, this
is what happens.
This view has its
own on pause, on
stop, on resume methods.
And it is your responsibility
when you add that view to an
activity to call those methods
at the right time.
So we don't need to add support
for that in the framework.
You can do it yourself.
We know it's a bit more work.
But you can easily write utility
libraries or classes
in your code to help
you do that.
I briefly mentioned
traversals before.
And traversals are scheduled
in three different ways.
They can be scheduled
by animations.
And we're talking about the new
animation system that was
introduced in Honeycomb.
The old animation system is
actually part of drawing.
Traversals can also be triggered
by requestLayout and
Invalidate.
And this is what the traversal
looks like.
And if you want to be really
scared, go look at
ViewRootImpl.java in the
source code of Android.
And look there's a method called
perform traversals.
And try to understand
what it does.
Once again, I've been writing
code in that method for years.
And I still don't
quite get it.
Don't laugh.
It's true.
So we first start
with animation.
So with a new animation
system, there will be
callbacks related to animations
that will be
triggered at the beginning
of a traversal.
Then we're going to do the
measurement pass, then the
layout pass, and finally
the drawing pass.
The order that you see those
events on screen is
guaranteed.
If you see a layout, there will
always be a draw after.
You can't see a draw and
then the layout.
What can happen, though, is you
could have a measure in
the layout and not a draw.
Or you could have a draw but not
a measure in the layout.
The only tricky part here is
that the measure and the
layout always happen together.
You cannot have one without the
other, unless you're doing
something really bad in
your application.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So let's dive a little
bit deeper on
some of these topics.
So measurement and layout
is where we'll
go ahead and begin.
All views know how to measure
themselves and
lay out their content.
And leaf node views that don't
actually have any children
should measure their internally
displayed content
and go ahead and lay
that content out
during these two steps.
So ViewGroups on the other hand
organize, measure, and
lay out a series
of child views.
So RequestLayout is the first
step in this whole process.
At some point, some
piece of state
changed within your view.
RequestLayout is the signal to
the view system that it needs
to recalculate the measurement
and layout of the views.
So it means something
very specific in
terms of what changed.
I means that something changed
that can alter the size, and
by extension the layout within
all the ancestors moving up
the hierarchy.
So RequestLayout is recursive.
A change in the size of a leaf
node way down at the bottom of
the tree can influence the size
going all the way up the
tree as well.
ROMAIN GUY: And this is actually
one of the reasons
why we often mention that you
shouldn't have too many views
in your application,
in your UI.
And more importantly, we said
that you shouldn't have too
deep of a tree.
And this is one of the reasons,
because every time we
call RequestLayout, we have to
walk all the way back up.
So when you call RequestLayout
once, it
doesn't really matter.
But if you [? update ?] a lot of
views and every one of them
tries to go back up the tree,
it can take up a significant
amount of time.
We have optimizations in the
UI Toolkit to avoid doing
extra work.
But every bit can help.
ADAM POWELL: That's right.
So because of this process,
anything can change.
It can dramatically change the
way that the view's parent,
grandparent, or
great-grandparent measures and
lays out the other
views around it.
So on measure, it's
where your view
implements the measure step.
It's called by the actual
measure method within view to
determine the view's size.
In a ViewGroup, again, this
is a recursive process.
So ViewGroups will go ahead and
call measure on each one
of their child views.
And then they can use
the results to help
decide their own size.
So the parameters onMeasure
are these packed
measure spec values.
They're packed into
a 32-bit end.
So the make MeasureSpec method
goes ahead and packs a size
and a mode code into
these values.
And then the getSize and getMode
methods listed here
unpack them for you.
And we'll go ahead and talk a
little bit more about measure
spec modes in a bit.
When a ViewGroup is measured,
it has a responsibility to
make sure that it's child
views have been properly
measured as well.
A layout request may have
originated from a leaf node
deep down the hierarchy.
And depending on how a ViewGroup
decides to arrange
its children, one small change
in size down the leaf node can
drastically alter the
layout above it.
If this sounds expensive, it's
because it really can be.
Multi-pass measurement in
a ViewGroup is sometimes
necessary when you're trying
to resolve different
constraints for a layout.
But because of that, it can
really add up fast.
And this is usually a good
time to dust off your
algorithm analysis techniques.
So finally, onMeasure doesn't
actually return a value.
Instead you call
setMeasuredDimension to set
width and height explicitly.
This is enforced.
If you forget to do this, then
the framework is going to
throw an exception and
crash your app.
The sizes that you set here
are reported by the
getMeasuredWidth and
getMeasuredHeight methods, not
the normal getWidth and
getHeight methods you may be
familiar with.
This is because the process
is two step.
GetWidth and getHeight don't
actually have their values
initialized until layout
is complete.
So you can use the measured size
of these child views to
decide your own size or perform
any other bookkeeping
after the child's
measure returns.
So back to modes.
There are three different
modes.
The first one is EXACTLY.
And it means exactly
what it says.
This mode can be used if there's
a fixed size specified
or if the parent view has
otherwise calculated a fixed
size for it.
So if you're familiar with the
match parents that you might
set in the LayoutParams or
weight that you might use in
linear layout, these are good
examples of when we might use
the EXACTLY mode.
It's common to go ahead and do
a second pass to finalize a
measurement in a multi-pass
scenario.
And weight is one of these.
Since we distribute whatever
leftover weight is still
remaining after we've measured
all the child views, we use
EXACTLY to go ahead and lock in
the extra size to each one
of the child views.
So AT_MOST specifies an upper
bound with the implication
that the view should usually
be conservative with that.
The measured size should always
be less than or equal
to the size reported
in the MeasureSpec.
When you give a view width of
wrap content, then the stock
framework layouts will use
AT_MOST to measure that child.
The view has the option of
consuming up to that specified
size if it really wants to.
And finally, you have the
UNSPECIFIED mode.
This is where we just really
don't know anything enough to
tell you how to measure in this
particular dimension.
The view has potentially
infinite space
available to it.
So this is really common for
things like scroll containers,
so scroll view, list
view, et cetera.
The limits are based only on the
content that you're trying
to place there.
So most views still treat
this the same way that
they do with AT_MOST.
They just don't impose the
upper bound constraint.
The implication is that the view
should still try and be
as conservative as
possible and wrap
tightly around the content.
So making sure that you actually
get the right measure
specs that match what your child
views want, it can be a
little bit tricky.
There are few utilities in the
framework that can help out
with this, though.
One of these utilities is the
getChildMeasureSpec method.
It understands the standard
framework patterns for how
layout params and measure
specs should
interact with one another.
It's kind of a handshake between
the two that happens
during measurement
and the parent.
So for example, if a parent
has exactly 300 pixels
available to it and a child
wants to wrap content within
it, then the spec that we'll
actually send to that child is
300 pixels in the
AT_MOST mode.
So once measurement is complete,
layout is just a
matter of positioning
the child views that
we've already measured.
So usually this is where we
apply offsets, padding,
margins, so on and so forth.
And while ViewGroups can often
implement multi-pass
measurement to get things
just right, layout
will only happen once.
If there's some expensive
computation that you need to
perform during the whole measure
layout sequence, then
you should really try and defer
it to layout if you can
to be more efficient.
That way you don't get caught
up in these multiple measure
passes that can happen.
And even if your own custom
view doesn't do multiple
measure passes, some view that's
further above you in
the hierarchy may be
performing that.
So you still want to be as
optimal as possible.
So this two phase measurement
in layout means that you'll
often want a way to get at some
of the data that you've
already computed in onMeasure
so that you don't have to
compute it twice.
GetMeasuredWidth and Height are
always there for you to
use for this purpose.
But sometimes you need to have
more info than that.
You'll want to wait for child
views to communicate extra
configuration data to your
layout code in general, such
as gravity, for one example.
ROMAIN GUY: We're going to
talk about LayoutParams.
But just before we get started,
so we mentioned the
three different measure
spec modes.
It's real scary and intimidating
when you're
trying to write a custom view
and you think about how can I
implement all those modes?
You don't have to.
If you write a custom view and
you know exactly how it's
going to be used in your UI, you
know it's always going to
be match parent, match parent,
just implement the measure
spec exactly.
That's the big difference
between what you can do in a
custom view.
You can cut corners.
You can cheat.
You can make it a lot
more efficient.
And what we can do in our views
in the framework is we
have to make them work in
all possible situations.
So our code is a lot more
complicated and harder to
[? optimize ?]
than what you can do.
And this is why we keep telling
people, you should try
to create custom views whenever
you can, because you
can make them a lot easier to
write and much more efficient
than the ones that we have.
For instance, if you are trying
use all the different
widgets that we have in the UI
Toolkit to create a really
complex UI and it doesn't quite
work, you can write a
custom view instead.
It's going to be easier.
You might spend less time
writing that Java code than
trying to come up with the magic
XML incantation that's
going to do what you want.
And it's also going to
be more efficient.
So to create the measure specs
for your children, if you're
writing a custom view that
extends ViewGroups, or if
you're writing a custom layout,
you will be very
interested in LayoutParams.
So LayoutParams, you know
what they are from
XML most of the time.
They are all those attributes
that sell to layout
underscore, and a map to a class
that is typically called
LayoutParams.
And it's static in your class
of the layout it belongs to.
So the base class is called
ViewGroup.LayoutParams.
But we also have
LinearLayout.LayoutParams.
We have
FrameLayout.LayoutParams, and so on.
You don't have to
do it this way.
This is just the recommended
way.
The base LayoutParams
class will give you
a width and a height.
There's another one
you can use.
It's called margin
layout params.
It will give you the extra
margin parameters if you need
bespoke margins in your
customer group.
So LayoutParams are really
dumb objects.
They are just here
to store data.
They just store the arguments
that you're getting from the
view when it's added
to the ViewGroup.
So either from code--
when you say add view, you press
the view, then the set
of LayoutParams--
or from XML, you can
[? import ?] the
LayoutParams from XML.
And you know about the
width and height.
But in LinearLayout, we
mentioned the weight.
This is one of the params
that we store in
LinearLayout.LayoutParams.
It's always a mouthful
[INAUDIBLE].
ADAM POWELL: It is.
ROMAIN GUY: We need
to rename them.
Beyond LayoutParams.
So if you create custom
LayoutParams because you want
more than the width and the
height, there are four other
methods that you should
implement
in your custom ViewGroup.
So we have one called
check LayoutParams.
This is invoked when you add
a view to a ViewGroup.
If that group already has
LayoutParams attached to it,
we're going to call check
LayoutParams to see if those
LayoutParams are compatible
with the ViewGroup.
So usually what views
do here, it's just
an instance of check.
So if you look at LinearLayout,
it just does the
parameters instance of
LinearLayout.LayoutParams.
But you could do a lot more.
If you have a lot of custom
parameters, you could vary the
constraints, for instance, and
throw an exception if they
don't work.
Generic LayoutParams, the
texture LayoutParams
attribute, can be used
to do conversion.
So if you add a view that was
previously in the frame layout
and it has frame layout
LayoutParams, and then that
view is added to your ViewGroup,
and if you know how
to convert those frame layouts,
LayoutParams in your
LayoutParams, you can do
so in that method.
Generic LayoutParams within an
attribute set, this is what's
used when we inflate the
LayoutParams from XML.
So the default behavior here
that we use-- actually, that's
what we use all the time--
we just call the constructor
or LayoutParams [INAUDIBLE]
the attribute set.
And all the work
is done there.
And finally, default
LayoutParams.
If you don't specify
LayoutParams when you add a
view from code, we're going to
try to guess what's the best
configuration for ViewGroup.
So typically in the frame
layout, we're going to do
match parents, match parents.
A linear layout will do
something like wrap content,
wrap content, something
like that.
But don't forget that
LayoutParams can also be used
to store private data.
So if you do a lot of expensive
computations during
the measure pass or even doing
the layout pass, you can store
all that data per child
in the LayoutParams.
So if you go look at the source
code of RelativeLayout,
for instance, that's exactly
what it does.
It does its own private fields
to keep track of
what's going on.
I want to talk briefly
about drawing.
We won't spend too much time on
it, because we have a lot
of other sessions
about rendering.
But the way to trigger a joint
traversal is to call
Invalidate.
I'm sure a lot of you are
familiar with that method.
And just like with the
RequestLayout, it's a
recursive algorithm.
So it's going to walk
up the tree.
So I'm going to call Invalidate
on the parents
[INAUDIBLE]
something called
InvalidateChild.
And those methods are actually
pretty expensive.
RequestLayout is pretty cheap
because all it does, it sends
a flag saying I want
to layout.
Invalidate has to keep track of
animations, of bounds, of
transforms, things like that.
So again, if you go look at the
source code that occurs,
you'll see that it's not a
trivial method to call.
Again, we try to optimize
those calls.
So if you have two siblings
of a ViewGroup that call
Invalidate, only one of them
will go all the way up.
Calling Invalidate without any
parameters will mark the
entire view as dirty.
There's a variant of Invalidate
that takes four
parameters.
It's a sub-rectangle of the view
that you want to redraw.
So whenever you can, if you have
enough information about
what's going on inside the
view, try to use a second
variant of the method.
It will be a lot cheaper for
the UI Toolkit and for your
application to do the redraw
when we come back down.
So once we call Invalidate,
we're going to call the draw
method on your view, and
possibly on other views.
So the draw method in the base
view class is final.
You cannot override that method,
because it does a lot
of bookkeeping that we don't
want you to mess with.
And trust me, you really
don't want to have
to deal with that.
Draw will invoke the methods
that you can override.
So the first one is
called onDrawing.
I'm sure a lot of you are
familiar with that method.
So how many of you have ever
implemented the onDraw method?
That's really good.
ADAM POWELL: They have
lots of experience.
ROMAIN GUY: So the only goal
of the onDraw method is to
draw the content of the view.
You don't have to draw
a background.
The base view class, the draw
method will do that for you.
But any other content you want
to draw, like text view.
That's where you do it.
There's a little trick.
We have a method that--
I hate that name.
It's so confusing--
setWillNotDraw(true).
Again, after six years, still
get it wrong every time
I try to use it.
And it's even worse, because
internally it's implemented as
a bit inside the [INAUDIBLE].
So with all the mess that
you have to use,
it gets really confusing.
ViewGroup by default
will set that flad.
So when that flag is set, you
promise that you do not want
to do anything.
Your children will draw.
But you're not been going
to draw anything.
You don't have a background.
You don't want to draw anything
on top of your children.
So in that case, we're going
to skip the onDraw call.
And we're going to call directly
in the other method
called dispatchDraw.
And dispatchDraw is another
pretty complex method.
But you can override it.
It's responsible for drawing
the children.
And this is where we apply all
the transforms, like the
alpha, rotation, scaling, and
animations with the old
animation system.
And for every child, we
call a method called
ViewGroup.drawChild.
So if you want to override that
method entirely, make
sure that you call the drawChild
method for every one
of your children.
Otherwise you're not going to
get animations working or
transforms.
There's a big difference between
software and hardware
rendering in the way we call
those drawing methods.
So as I mentioned before, we
introduced hardware rendering
in Android 3.0.
And in software, if you call
Invalidate, we're going to
call the draw method of every
view that's a parent of the
view that called Invalidate.
We are also going to call the
draw method of any view that
intersects with the
dirty region.
So if you have views stacked on
top of each other, and even
if they're siblings, we are
going to call a draw method on
every one of those views.
So it can be pretty expensive.
In hardware, however, we are a
completely different system.
And I won't go into
details here.
There was a talk two years
ago explaining
how it works exactly.
But only the view that calls
Invalidate will see its draw
method invoked.
This is much more efficient.
You can imagine that if you have
10 parents, and suddenly
we have to call only one method
instead of 11, it's
going to be a lot faster.
So you can refer to that talk,
"Accelerated Android
Rendering," where we explained
in detail how the new
rendering system works.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So a lot of your views are going
to have instant state.
This is some extra information
that you're going to want to
be able to save for later.
Android app components
can come and go
at any time, remember.
So process containers
get killed.
Activities get recreated if you
change the orientation or
something else changes.
But views can actually save
their own state for later in a
way that can be persisted
by the system.
So two methods control this
save and restore process,
named onSaveInstanceState and
onRestoreInstanceState.
And the easiest way to write
one of these instance state
objects that gets persisted is
to extend the base saved state
in a static inner class
of your view.
And this establishes conventions
for how sub class
and super class state get
organized within this
persistent bundle.
So the standard naming
convention is just in a class
called saved state
within your view.
Views need to have an ID for
their instance state to be
saved and restored.
This is really important.
This also needs to be unique
within your view hierarchy.
This is how we actually match up
what data to pump back into
the onRestore method when your
views get recreated.
So if you duplicate the ID
within multiple views within
your hierarchy, we're going to
restore that same state to
multiple views, which probably
isn't what you want.
So the mechanisms behind
actually saving the instance
state are pretty well
documented.
But what you save is a more
interesting question.
Don't bother saving anything
that's a part
of your data model.
Instead, save things that are
a reflection of the views
state as it relates to the
user's interaction with it.
So you really want to
keep these concerns
as separate as possible.
Normal data loading within your
app is going to take care
of reflecting the state
of your data model.
There's really no reason to save
it a second time and have
multiple sources of truth.
Instead, the view instance
state should take care of
leaving the details where
the user left them.
So things like uncommitted user
input can be a little bit
of a grey area in this, like
text entered in the field if
you have a really long
form, for example.
In many cases, we'll go ahead
and save this for you.
So Edit Text will automatically
persist whatever
text the user's entered.
ROMAIN GUY: So basically you're
telling people to not
be like a webpage--
like when you reload the webpage
and all your stuff
disappears?
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, basically.
So next we have touch events.
Touch events are fun.
They're really a key
component of any
interactive view these days.
So the basic event handling,
again, is well documented.
But what happens when it
gets more complex?
What happens when you actually
have views at multiple levels
of the hierarchy that
need to negotiate?
Well, first off, it's important
to know what a
consistent event stream means.
Android has this idea of a
consistent event stream when
it comes to motion
event objects.
This is a guarantee from other
parts of the view system to
your views.
You really shouldn't break this
guarantee you when you
write your views and
you end up sending
events to other views.
You want to make sure that
these guarantees hold.
So ACTION_DOWN starts
a new gesture.
It's really the beginning
of a touch interaction.
It's when the first touch point
contacts the stream.
And then throughout the course
of a gesture, you might get
additional ACTION_POINTER_DOWN
and ACTION_POINTER_UP events
as more touch points beyond
the first enter
and leave the screen.
Now each one of these pointers
has an ID attached to it.
And these can be used to track
the same touch point when you
have multiple touch
points active.
ACTION_POINTER_DOWN is the start
of a specific pointer
becoming valid.
And UP is that pointer
becoming invalid.
So while a gesture is in
progress, you'll get the
steady stream of action
move events as those
pointers move around.
These events contain info about
every touch point that's
currently in contact
with the screen.
And you'll have been told about
each and every one of
these through either the
initial ACTION_DOWN or
ACTION_POINTER_DOWN events.
And if any of them leave the
screen, you'll be told through
an ACTION_POINTER_UP or the
final ACTION_UP event.
ACTION_UP or ACTION_CANCEL ends
the current gesture in
progress entirely.
It means the user is done
interacting with the screen
for the time being.
ACTION_UP means that
it ended normally.
ACTION_CANCEL means that
something else took the user's
control away from your view.
So what this means is that
ACTION_UP is where you should
do things like fling, or
actually apply a click event.
Whereas ACTION_CANCEL should
never commit an action,
because you never really know
what took the user's control
away from that view.
Now when you have multiple views
working together to form
your UI's full touch
interaction, it's important to
factor that interaction
appropriately across your
different views.
Now Android gives you several
tools for views to collaborate
and decide which view should
actually be responsible for
handling a current touch
interaction.
Now onTouchEvent is the
simplest of these.
If a view returns true from
onTouchEvent for an initial
ACTION_DOWN, then the rest of
the event stream will be sent
to that view.
So it'll try and find the
deepest view that will accept
a touch event.
It's kind of like focus for
touch events, really.
Now parent views have an
additional method that they
can use for this, and that's
onInterceptTouchEvent.
This will be called for each
event that one of the parent
views' children receives.
By returning true for this, the
parent can go ahead and
steal the event stream away
from the child view.
The child will get an
ACTION_CANCEL event, since
that's what a view receives
whenever the event stream is
taken away from it
for some reason.
And the parent will receive the
rest of the current events
stream through its own
onTouchEvent method, not
through the
onInterceptTouchEvent method.
Now onIntercept is a great way
to implement things like
scrolling and dragging.
But it can really be
insufficient if you have
several levels of
nested views.
Now list views inside view pages
are a great example.
So to handle this case, we
have this method that--
what is it with our framework
having all these mouthful of
constants and methods in here?
ROMAIN GUY: We have to be very
specific in the names.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
So we have requestDisallowI
nterceptTouchEvent.
Now by calling this method on a
parent view, a view can stop
the parent's onIntercept method
from being called for
the remaining events
in the gesture.
And in the case of something
like the list view inside the
view pager, list view
invokes this method.
And then it actually will lock
the pager to the current page.
The pager or has no idea that
you're moving back and forth
left and right.
And so therefore you won't move
between pages if you just
want to make a really sloppy
scroll within that list.
So speaking of sloppy
scrolling--
well, in a second.
One way or another, these
three methods, when put
together, it means that you
can write custom views and
ViewGroups without being too
concerned about how you're
going to compose them.
And this is really important.
It means that you can keep all
these concerns separate within
the different custom views
that you might write.
The right thing will just happen
naturally as long as
you don't nest strolling
along the same axis.
I mean, how many times have we
all been using a webpage, and
we'll go ahead and scroll with
a mouse wheel or something
like that, and then suddenly
scrolling stops because there
was this other internally
scrolling region that your
cursor just happened to
be hovering over?
You don't want to build that
within a touch UI.
For this whole game of rock,
paper, scissors to work, you
really an opportunity to
determine the user's intent
before committing to one action
versus the other.
And view configuration is a
class in the framework that
has a lot of constants and other
values that control how
the framework tunes these
sorts of things.
In this case, you have
getScaledTouchSlot.
Now this is going to be a
distance reported back to you
in pixels adjusted for the
density of the current screen
that is the distance that you
have to travel in terms of
touch motion before you actually
commit to scrolling
within that view.
So having this slop within that
gets checked within your
onIntercept method for a
scrolling container means that
the child views have an
opportunity to say, no,
actually I want this event
stream, and call
requestDisallowI
nterseptTouchEvent up to the
parent, so on and so forth.
ROMAIN GUY: And view
configuration is a very useful
class if you're doing anything
useful with your custom view,
like touch handling, or even
animations or drawing.
You might want to take a look at
view configuration and the
kind of data it exposes.
Because everything in that class
is meant to help you be
consistent with the existing
UI Toolkit.
So if you need a duration, there
may be a duration in
there that matches your needs.
So make sure to take
a look at it.
And the class is actually
pretty well documented.
You can once again look at the
source code of the Android
platform and see
how we use it.
So we have four minutes
left for questions.
So if you have a question,
please walk up to the mics in
the aisles.
And before you leave the
room, there are bar
codes by the door.
You can scan them if you want
to rate the session.
And we'll be at the office hours
on the floor to answer
all your questions throughout
the day.
ADAM POWELL: That's right.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question.
I want to implement view that's
like a heartbeat, like
it's pulsing.
But what I want it to do is I
will have that method like it
posts every second or so.
And I wanted animation
that posts back.
So how should I do that?
Should I have in my view some
kind of timer that draws the
circle smaller and smaller
every 20 milliseconds?
Should this be part
of the view?
ROMAIN GUY: So you should
definitely use
the animation framework.
And tomorrow I'm giving a talk
with Chet Haase on animations.
And this is the kind of
animation that we're going to
talk about.
AUDIENCE: And the other quick
one is some phones send you
back an app event after 15
seconds, something like that,
that's in the original
[? matrix. ?]
I want to have a little button
which is press and hold.
But after 15 seconds, it
give me app event.
How can I do that?
ADAM POWELL: That was the
same on the Motorola
Zoom, wasn't it?
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
Sounds like a bug in the
[? touch dryer. ?]
AUDIENCE: Any workaround for
this, that you know about?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ADAM POWELL: Unfortunately
that's one of those things
where there are some devices out
there with touch firmware
that try and do this.
It's basically because the
device is trying to account
for a noise or other sources of
error that might be in the
environment so that you don't
have this permanent touch
point down.
Unfortunately, it ends up being
way too aggressive.
Because if you're in a case
where you're holding down the
gas pedal in a racing game, or
something like that, that
becomes really problematic.
And unfortunately, there's just
not a whole lot you can
do about it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So when you started, you
mentioned that there was a
blog post about RelativeLayouts
that was
misinterpreted.
Yeah, it was misinterpreted.
Everybody I know follows that.
So could you elaborate
on that a little bit?
ROMAIN GUY: So I think the
original post was about not
using a linear layout with an
image in the text view and
using only a single text view.
Or maybe you could use only--
no.
It was about using a
RelativeLayout to avoid
nesting linear layouts.
AUDIENCE: That and weights,
I think, as well, right?
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, something
like that.
ADAM POWELL: It was specifically
in the context of
list items, too, right?
ROMAIN GUY: That's correct.
So it was the context of list
items to avoid nesting a
vertical linear layout in a
horizontal linear layout.
So it's still true, if
you're using weights.
But using your RelativeLayout
to do everything is not the
right answer.
So if a firm layout does the job
because you need to stack
views, or if you just want to
put the view side by side, go
view linear layout
or firm layout.
A RelativeLayout will always
do two measure passes.
So when you nest,
then, you get an
exponential measurement algorithm.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROMAIN GUY: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have a
custom view that was
a background shadow.
And I noticed that it
works OK until 4.2.
And in 4.2, I get some visual
artifacts that are strange.
Is there anything that changed
in the rendering?
ROMAIN GUY: Not that
I can think of.
It might be a bug on our side.
Or you might have been
relying on the but
that existed before.
I would need to see code
and a running example.
Send me an APK that
[? repositions ?]
the issue.
And we can take a look
at it and see if it's
a bug on our side.
ADAM POWELL: Or if you'd like
we'll be in the Sandbox.
ROMAIN GUY: For office
hours, yes.
AUDIENCE: If possible,
another question.
Is there an easy way to add
margins to a list item entry?
ROMAIN GUY: To what?
AUDIENCE: To a list view
entry to add margins?
Because the margins are
cut by the list view.
ROMAIN GUY: Oh, you should
use the padding instead.
AUDIENCE: Even if we
have a background?
ROMAIN GUY: Well, use padding
in the parent view.
And then you put the
background inside.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ROMAIN GUY: Thank you.
We are out of time.
Come to the office hours
in the Sandbox.
ADAM POWELL: Yep, happy to
answer your questions at
office hours.
Thanks.